[Applause]
you know we didn't want anyone to go
home empty-handed tonight because we
think that you are all winners even
though you are not
so we got some consolation prizes
because this is going to make you feel
better right it's going to make
everybody feel better absolutely okay
now here's something what's that i have
a movie uh-huh for somebody special and
no one has ever seen this movie never
been seen it's a never been seen movie
okay okay not even by the director uh-oh
now i got a screener of the last duel
never been seen
never been seen
okay
nobody want it i hold on can you hold on
to that one okay uh you know what okay
like you you like democracy right you
like democracy well here is a voter's
registration form for the state of texas
oh boy look at that oh not again
they come free shred it now look at that
look at that
there you go you take that there you go
uh let me see javier you into uh you
heard you heard of nfts right
yeah guess what yeah we just going with
the fts this is a fungible token oh yeah
all right so you enjoy that that's going
to be worth a lot uh-huh now
what you got there she is uh-huh
judy danny dame judy davis no we got
something for you yes yes now you know
what
we got an inspirational quote for you
because you because you didn't win
tonight that's right that's right and
this is from uh
a quote from kim kardashian
work harder that's right that's what we
need you to do you got it
you got to move that ass thing
you got to move it
you got to move it
you